[Music]
hello how are you greetings sal y jaramillo
with your report of the day an accident in the
southwest of the valley left two people
hospitalized today the accident occurred
on sunday afternoon near the
streets of querer and spain mount saint
according to the police both  Drivers
were taken to the hospital and one of
them had serious injuries. Until
now, the exact cause of the
accident is unknown and officials are expected to reveal
new information about the accident of the
bus that left Las Vegas for
the Grand Canyon on Friday in which they
were traveling.  48 people the truck overturned
in northwest arizona and the accident
claimed the life of a passenger it was reported
that three other passengers also
suffered serious injuries but stable
in the hospital the cause of the accident
has not been determined but at least one
firefighter who responded to  the scene
said speed may have been a
factor and the fbi is currently
working on returning the belongings
of  all the people who attended
the concert in which the shooting took place
on oct.
their belongings
but the fbi is asking people who
have yet to be contacted by the agency
to contact the
resiliency center for more information
please visit
our page youtube.com
snowfall coronavirus infections continue to decline
yesterday
reported 15  deaths but also the
state has recorded fewer tests and the
state of nevada currently ranks
last in the entire country in its plan
to distribute the
coronavirus vaccine something that officials hope to
change on Monday reopens the
vaccination mega site in the  Jasmine
Sener, which they had to close on Friday and
during the weekend.  weekdays for
scheduled renovations and currently
the largest vaccination site in
southern nevada right
now the state is only
vaccinating
healthcare workers as well as people over
the age of 70
and las vegas will have representation at the
highly anticipated game of  super bowl 55
player jon knudsen is a
crazy high school graduate facebook train and plays
for his weather buccaneers team
so we send him
congratulations and good luck now
we move on with your weather forecast
expecting a rainy day breezy  and
temperatures in the 40s as well as a
chance of rain and snow until
tomorrow morning have a good day
I am this light of mine and this was x in
Spanish
[Music]